>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> Nicholas Brown: Good
afternoon, Ladies and Gentlemen.
Welcome to the Library of
Congress in the Whiptail Pavilion.
My name is Nicholas Brown,
and I'm a music specialist
and concert producer here.
We're very pleased to continue our
program of lectures this season
with today's talk featuring
Leonard Schmieding,
who is a DEAD Visiting Researcher
at the BMW Center for German
and European Studies at Georgetown.
He earned his PhD in history with
a dissertation on hip-hop culture
in the German Democratic Republic
at the University of Leipzig,
and he has a book out called
"Das ist unsere Party,"
right, is that right?
Yay [laughter].
Trying. You can see a list
of his other publications
in the program for today.
He's also had great experiences in
exhibit curator and as an instructor
at the university level as well.
So we hope you enjoy this talk.
There will be a period
for Q&A at the end.
And do take a peek at the brochure
that's inside your program,
which is the list of events for
the European Month of Culture.
On Friday evening, we are
partnering with the Finnish Embassy
to present Kaija Saariaho
premier of a Library
of Congress co-commission
featuring Jennifer Koh, violin,
Leva Jokubaviciute, who
is a Lithuanian pianist,
and Anssi Karttunen, who
is a Finnish cellist.
So do check us out on Friday night
at 8:00, and we hope you enjoy.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Leonard Schmieding:
Well, thank you, Nick,
thank you, Library of Congress.
This is a fantastic venue, and
I'm super thrilled to be here
and share my insights
about hip-hop culture
in the German Democratic Republic.
Also providing some light
lunchtime entertainment.
So let me take you back on a
trip to 1984, a little bit more
than 30 years ago, when the movie
"Beat Street" introduced
hip-hop culture to audiences
in America and in Europe.
In its first five minutes,
which I'm showing you here,
you will find everything
you need to know in order
to understand this spread of hip-hop
into the German Democratic
Republic in the mid-'80s.
So here's the movie.
>> "Beat Street, Beat
Street, Beat Street."
>> Leonard Schmieding: Okay,
so much for the light lunchtime
entertainment [laughter].
So these first five minutes showed
basically or gives an introduction
about hip-hop culture and the
elements, as we call them,
that made it over the Iron
Curtain, which is of course DJing,
you see that at the very end at the
party, the rapping, also emceing,
right, the DJ is also the rapper.
And you have B-Boying, the
little brother of Kenny,
the double K. DJ is Lee Kirkland,
he's the little B-Boy with his crew,
you can see on the right.
And it's actually B-Boy
crew from New York City,
so it's the New York City Breakers.
And then you have Ramo or Ramon,
their Puerto Rican friend.
He's a graffiti artist, or
a writer, as some call him.
And you had these first
five minutes as a way
of showing how these four elements
come together and interact.
In my presentation today, I will
analyze the culture transfer
of hip-hop that Beat
Street triggered
in the German Democratic Republic.
I will start by focusing on the
feature film "Beat Street" itself.
And I'll show how it not only served
as a mentor for hip-hop aficionados
in the coming, but also why
it was imported, released,
and highly acclaimed in the GDR
by the officials of the Ministry
of Culture and the media.
I will then give a short overview of
authorities and cultural functions.
The People's Police and the Ministry
of State Security that is also known
under the name of Stasi and
how they dealt with hip-hop
and its teenage petitioners.
In the main part of my talk though,
I will flush out how hip-hop heads
in the GDR appropriated
hip-hop culture.
How they created hip-hop fashion
and dance, spray-painted graffiti,
and made music with
DJing and rapping.
In my analysis of this
teenage fascination
with American popular
culture is German socialism.
I argue that many hip-hop
petitioners became black.
I'm here referring to Americanist
and ethnologist Moritz Ege's study,
which is becoming black, about
AfroAmericanophilia in West Germany.
And I follow his definition
of AfroAmericanophilia
as a cultural theme.
That is the appreciative
appropriation and perception
of cultural forms and
colored as black.
And the analogous relationship
to black people and/or
their representations.
Becoming black then
means an imaginary
and symbolic identification
with African-Americans.
Consequently, in my close readings
of youth performing hip-hop
in the GDR, I will flush
out how they identified
with African-Americans on an
imaginary and on a symbolic level.
So let's first look at "Beat
Street" as a cultural mobilizer.
Since it was impossible
to directly interact
with African-American agents
of hip-hop culture like it was
in West Germany, and then learn
about and get involved in it,
teenagers in East Germany
got in touch
with it through other channels.
Radio, television,
and most importantly,
the feature film "Beat Street."
So before "Beat Street" came in
1985, teenagers would be aware
of hip-hop through Western German
TV programs and radio stations.
And they were streaming, of course,
from Berlin, which was basically
in the middle of the GDR, and
they could receive these stations
very well.
Or from the radio and TV towers that
were very close to the Iron Curtain,
and you could receive
these programs quite well.
But then came "Beat Street."
Beat Street boosted the evolution
and spread of hip-hop culture
in the GDR, not only by amplifying
teenage interest and involvement
in breakdancing, DJing,
and rapping, and graffiti,
but also by depicting
America in a way
that the cultural authorities
found acceptable.
In this respect, the film also
served as a point of reference
for official appropriations
of hip-hop culture.
"Beat Street" made it onto the
GDR screens for two reasons then.
One, it could be categorized
as a so-called problem film.
That is a film criticizing
the United States
and thus educating its East
German viewers about the dangers
of American capitalism, racism,
oppression, and exploitation.
And two, at the same time,
it promised to draw an
audience large enough
to make it a so-called
[foreign language],
the socialist name
for a blockbuster.
That is a movie with which East
Germany could make enough money
to then finance its
own cinema industry.
While it is pretty clear that with
3 million tickets sold between 1985
and 1990, "Beat Street" was indeed
a [inaudible], I highly doubt
that teenage hip-hop
heads interpreted the film
as the officials had intended.
So let's first look at the way that
the Ministry of Culture perceived
and then rated the movie.
The Ministry of Culture's
head office for film approved
"Beat Street" for public
screening in March 1985.
And it premiered GDR-wide
on June 15, 1985.
So almost exactly 30 years ago.
Not only did the cultural
functionary seize the very first
opportunity to watch the movie,
with the delegation traveling
to West Berlin to attend its West
German premiere on July 27, 1984,
but they also processed its
approval in only eight months.
A very short period compared
to the approval process
for other Hollywood productions,
and even other socialists ones.
It was faster than any
Soviet movie in the 1980s,
so that shows you how
they wanted this movie.
The interpretation of "Beat Street"
explained why this American movie
should be screened in the GDR.
[inaudible], of the Progress
Film Distribution Company,
that handled the approval process,
stressed the aspects of community,
of living in the ghetto,
and the role hip-hop plays
for the protagonists in coping
with their everyday lives.
This emphasis paved the way
for a very favorable review.
The company recommended the film be
approved for its social criticism,
its staging of music and dance,
and its attractiveness
to a young audience.
And I quote, "The film
impressively shows where the roots
of this new-called wave -- new
wave called hip-hop, of breakdance,
graffiti paintings, and
rap music, are to be found.
The film achieves its
authentic character especially
through its many original locations.
Which put on display the forbidding
and disintegrating street blocks
where the black populations live,
and by casting the main characters
with youngsters who live in this
new youth, who really do breakdance
in the subway, on the
streets, etcetera.
Music and dance connect and
determine the plot of the film,
they are not presented as mere show.
Because as in the movie, they are in
the center of the youngsters' lives.
The boys are usually out of work
after leaving school, so that dance,
music, and painting help
them to pass the time."
Getz furthermore tied "Beat
Street's" achievements
to its producer, Harry Belafonte,
who she lauded for his involvement
in the Peace Movement
and Black Emancipation.
She regarded Belafonte as a
warranty that the movie constituted,
"not only an effectively
staged musical,
but also an unmasking narrative
about the life of youngsters
in the black ghetto of New York."
And years later, in an interview,
she recounted that, "with its story
and way of depicting it, "Beat
Street" matched well with the image
that we wanted to convey
of America."
The cultural authorities
interpretive goal then the way they
wanted youth in the GDR to watch
and understand the film was geared
towards raising consciousness
for America as a bad place, because
of its capitalist exploitation,
which created ghettos
and discriminated
against African-Americans.
The goal was in line with the
official interpretation of hip-hop
as so-called second culture.
And this goes back to
Lenin, the communist leader.
And the term was made popular then
by the East German Historian
Chazenski [assumed spelling],
a very central figure in
the Academy of Sciences.
So what he said had great value.
And it basically meant international
working-class culture as a struggle
against [inaudible] and
capitalist oppression.
Accordingly, the ensemble of
breakdance, rap, and DJing,
and graffiti was ignored because
they didn't know what to do with it.
In the Bronx, was regarded
as anti-capitalist protests
and potential revolt
against corporate America.
And accordingly, cultural
functionaries encouraged its
practice as display of solidarity
with the oppressed masses
in the United States.
I should mention that
in this official view,
there was no acknowledgment
or appreciation of blackness
or black expressive
cultures, like blues and jazz,
which hip-hop heavily references
in all of its practices.
So it was basically
detached from all of that.
It was made working-class culture,
and you had to show your solidarity
with it, so the GDR will be open to
the world and revolution, of course.
Encouraging the practice of
hip-hop on GDR soil meant
that the authorities conceded to the
fact that they could not stop it.
So the hip-hop motto "Can't
stop, won't stop," also works
in GDR context [laughter].
What they could not stop, they
had to contain and to control
in order to make it socialist.
And they resorted to
two major strategies.
First, handing out official licenses
which categorized B-Boys, DJs,
and rappers as artists, sometimes
also called entertainment artists,
in the category acrobatic
folk dance [laughter],
or merely voice singing, right.
So the youngsters have
to obtain these licenses
and official performances
for a committee
that evaluated their
quality and then handed
out their ID cards as artists.
While the teenage artists were
allowed to perform for anyone
who wanted to book them, they
also had to attach themselves
to a cultural institution
that agreed to sponsor them.
Artistic freedom, of
course, looks different.
But usually the hip-hop heads have
found ways to undermine this kind
of control, by the way they danced.
I mean, after all, no experts --
there were no experts in these
assessment committees, right.
Who was an expert on
breakdance in the GDR?
Like ballet instructors?
I don't think so [laughter].
Then also by the way
they clad themselves,
like they made the fashion.
They usually wore like self-made
Puma T-shirts or Adidas sweaters.
Or if you noticed in "Beat Street,"
the whole attire was
sponsored by Puma.
And they actually like
financed the movie.
Product placement at
its finest, right.
And then also by the way they mixed
the music for their performances.
As some of you might or
might not know, in the GDR,
you couldn't just play any music
you wanted in public for discos.
At least 60% had to be from
so-called socialist countries,
and 40% could stem from
not socialist countries.
But if you know what mixing is in
DJ culture and hip-hop culture,
you just take snippets, right.
So 60/40 doesn't really work.
So that's how they kind of
evaded the whole being controlled
by this quota system.
And the second major strategy was
to produce socialist hip-hop music
that could be used
for parties and bands,
and that would eventually
supplant America rap music, right.
So the music that you heard on "Beat
Street" was okay but not really
because it came from America
still and from record companies.
So one thought, okay, why don't
we produce our own hip-hop music.
And here's an example, an
early example, from 1985,
and it's Arnold Fritzsch's,
Elektrik Boogie.
So here again, the ghetto
pictures from "Beat Street."
And this is it's like [inaudible].
It's four songs.
Du bist so HeiB you're so hot.
Elektrik Boogie is Elektrik Boogie.
Neon Dschungel is Neon Dschungel
and then O-O-O [laughter].
Which also kind of
which sums it up, oh.
[Music] Okay, these are not
real [inaudible] I guess.
So I said, this is an early example,
and needless to say there were
not really any late examples,
because they figured
out soon that this kind
of substituting American
rap music didn't work.
But [inaudible] Fit, the
composer and producer
who did this whole special disco mix
here, he was a well known composer
and he worked for the
state quite often.
And he also worked
with like B-Boy crews.
And the state usually wanted
to like be modern and wanted
to give its youth what it wanted,
at least, the state wanted to figure
out how they could do this.
So every two years,
they had a big meeting
in a town called [inaudible],
which was about disco
culture and entertainment.
And it was there in 1984 that
they talked about how they could
like incorporate like the hip-hop
in their official socialist culture.
Didn't work.
Okay, the whole pop
project proved a failure.
Later, in 1987 in December, and then
all the way through 1988 and 1989,
the radio station Good
Vibrations, which translated
from German [foreign
language], right.
But the host wanted to call it
Good Vibrations, but wasn't allowed
to because English wasn't allowed.
But he call it [foreign
language], which is the same.
But he played American
rap music all the time,
and more and more and more.
Like he started out
with one hour at night,
and then he got two hours
in the early evening.
And then twice a week
he had a show that ran
for four hours and with black music.
He also played African
music, but mainly hip-hop.
And in his moderations,
in his like spoken word,
he always interpreted songs by
Public Enemy, Run DMC, Kurtis Blow,
and so forth, and talked about
it in the second culture terms.
So it was very smart,
after all, he was some kind
of an official representating
the socialist culture.
But then he just played
a whole side of record,
and he knew that the
youngsters would sit in front
of their radio recorders and just
record the whole half of the record.
And he would have, again,
some text and then say,
and now for the second
half, [laughter],
and played the second half.
He also played like
amateur productions
that the GDR or youth produced.
But I talk about that
a little later.
So again, these two strategies,
they didn't really work,
but they were measures of control.
And in the official
perception, the first strategy,
it usually worked,
because on the outside.
Usually these young B-Boy crews,
they got they obtained
their licenses
and then they were conforming
to the rules, and, you know,
conforming to the regulations,
and it was all good.
When it did not, they were punished.
And usually either the
People's Police came,
and if the People's Police turned
out to be not effective enough,
then the Stasi applied their surge
of monitoring and infiltrating
and disintegrating
nonconformance to hip-hoppers.
You had the whole gamut of,
you know, violence, of well,
not torture, but infiltrating
with an official informants
and so on and so forth.
But I did find some examples of this
rather brutal [inaudible] practice,
but the majority of hip-hop
crews conformed to the rules
and regulations and
steer clear of trouble.
Which, however, did not mean
that they were conformists
on the inside, quite
to the contrary.
I argue that because it was
so easy to play by the rules,
young hip-hoppers also played with
them, and ultimately used them
to express their grievances
with the GDR and to break
out of the confines of
the socialist state.
So let's look at how they did this,
and let's look at "Beat
Street" again.
So at glance, at the way
GDR teenagers appropriated
"Beat Street" reveals the wide gap
between the youth cultural
understanding of the film
and then the official goal.
For them "Beat Street" performed
authentic hip-hop culture.
For one thing, it enabled them
to meet real hip-hop stars,
their role models, albeit on
screen, Kool Herc, which you can see
on the right-hand side, DJ
Jazzy Jeff, Afrika Bambaataa,
you can see on the left-hand side.
And the New York City
Breakers, I already showed,
and then the Rock Steady
Crew, the rival dance crew,
and then Melle Mel,
of course, here too.
And then there are more stars, Kool
Moe Dee, Doug Fresh, two rappers,
and then Phase 2 is an
early graffiti artist
that some people might know.
But he doesn't really have a
person role, but only by way
of his pictures, of
his graffiti murals.
And then for another,
they were able to identify
with the everyday teenagers
in the movie
and observe them doing
their thing in hip-hop.
Kenny, the DJ and emcee,
Lee the B-Boy,
and Ramon, the graffiti artist.
And then that's the
slide you already know.
So what GDR youth had previously
pieced together on the basis
of media snippets from the West,
they could now view live almost,
in color, and basically anytime
they wanted for only 50 pennies.
So what they usually did was go to a
matinee, then to an early afternoon,
and then to a late night screening.
So back to back.
And they paid 50 pennies for each.
And that was pretty good for them.
"Beat Street" appealed to them
because of its style rather
than any political
message and its story.
Or, as the B-Boys themselves
recalled
about their viewing experience,
"what these teenagers had
in the Bronx and did with it was a
lot more stylish, was world's cooler
than anything we teenagers
in the GDR had."
In their self-fashioning,
GDR B-Boys, rappers,
emcees and graffiti artists
emulated "Beat Street" in many ways.
They performed their visions
of New York in their clothing,
in their graffiti, in their
DJ mixes and rap lyrics.
Posing in front of rundown houses
in central Dessau, for instance,
invoked a whiff of New York.
Meaning, of course, a ghetto
inner-city in the Bronx.
Equating the Bronx with inner-cities
in the GDR though challenged
the sanctioned marketing
of socialist cities, which held them
up as paragons of modern housing
for everyone, and relied on
spreading immaculate images
of progressive urban
socialist achievements, right,
these high-rises,
these prefabricated high-rise
buildings in the GDR.
Furthermore, this conjuring
up of black spaces
on their home turf
represents this symbolic
and imaginary identification
with African-Americans,
which is characteristic of this
GDR youth African-Americaofelia.
See here how they pose
in these houses,
how they have on the right-hand
upper side the back pieces
of graffiti, which they produce
on their own, it's all self-made.
They have the boom box as
something to, you know,
invade public space with.
And then the lower right-hand
outside picture is a nice kind
of way of looking at the sun I guess
[laughter], but just a cool pose.
So similarly, with the
practice of graffiti,
writers expressed themselves
visually and imagined themselves
into their visions of America
that enabled them to take part
in the transatlantic
culture of hip-hop.
They thus committed a
temporary [foreign language],
the flight from the
Republic of the GDR.
A short break from socialism, which
they thought constrained them,
in which constrained
them like the ghetto.
And if they had to live in
a ghetto, one could say,
they preferred the
Bronx over the GDR.
Although, of course, they did not
know what the Bronx really looked
like, right.
For them, equating the Bronx with
the GDR meant seeing hip-hop culture
as a way to overcome this
feeling of being ghettoized.
And this is what also they
saw in "Beat Street, right,
overcoming being constrained
to the ghetto.
Take, for example, the
writer Simo from Dresden.
At age 14, he watched "Beat
Street," and after that,
graffiti became his life.
The following graffiti sketch
is taken from his black book,
his sketchbook, of the 1980s,
shows how he's taken cues from
"Beat Street" and other
hip-hop media of the time.
So I interviewed him, I met him,
and then he gave me his
sketchbook and I photographed it.
See how he makes Simo his writer
name by dropping the final N
of his name, Simon, just like
Ramo, Ramon in "Beat Street."
Also note how he graphically bowed
to US rappers in New York City
as the birthplace of hip-hop.
You can see that on the right side.
He has all the lists, he
lists all the hip-hop stars.
And then there's the skyline of
New York, then there's the NY
with the Statue of Liberty, and
then there is the five Burroughs,
Brooklyn, Queens, Manhattan,
Bronx, and Holland.
And of course, he leaves out
Staten Island and inserts Harlem
and other black space, right.
Whether this is subconsciously
or consciously, I don't know,
but it speaks volumes about
how much they were focused
on on these black spaces.
His motives and comments suggest
that he iconically conceived
of himself as an African-American
writer living in New York.
He is, after all, a subway rider.
You can barely see, it's below
Simo, I am a subway rider,
you can see in pencil scribbling.
And then writing graffiti
with a personalized spray can,
which you can see on
the left-hand side.
Roaming the boroughs of New
York like his own neighborhoods.
He knows all the names and all
the places, as if he was a member
of the hip-hop scene there
and not in Dresden, right.
And he's in the Bronx.
Then a picture that can be disputed
quite controversially is if you look
at the Bronx picture, there's a
youngster with black skin obviously,
and then he has a blue shirt,
and then a red kind of tie,
which could be also at least
half officially Free German Youth
uniform, right.
So socialist mass organization
in communist times.
But that's just it's an
observation, it could be disputed.
For the members of the
state apparatus attempting
to control the practice of hip-hop,
these graffiti were difficult
to interpret, just like
the whole self-fashioning
of hip-hop heads proved
quasi-indecipherable
to these older generations.
And then one aspect at
complicating the control
of the youth culture was blackness.
On the one hand, it's seen in the
official praise for "Beat Street"
and Harry Belafonte,
African-Americans were perceived
as members of the international
working class,
and therefore, to be
synthesized with.
And on the other hand, they
were like teenagers in the GDR,
emulating blacks in the Bronx.
Sporting brands like Puma, listening
to American rap music in public,
and then also spray
painting graffiti,
and thereby like vandalizing
the property
of the state and the people.
Which is not okay [laughter].
But the police could not
always do something against it
and the Stasi could also not
always do something against it.
So let's look at some
rap culture in the music.
And I'm going to talk about a person
called TJ Big Blaster Electric
Boogie, that was his name.
Big Blaster because of the
ghetto blaster or the boom box,
and Electric Boogie, of
course, for the dancing style.
Electric B, as he also
called himself,
alluding to his New York idols like
Afrika Bambaataa, emcee Melee Mel,
or Erik B Roquiem, those he lists
as his most influential idols.
He organized a number of parties,
workshops, and contests in the city
of Dresden, especially
with a rap contest
and the rap workshop
in 1988 and in 1989.
He intended to bring together
hip-hop artists from all
over the GDR to form the
so-called universal hip-hop family.
The family, again, a reference to
Bambaataa and his Azula Nation,
was to organize hip-hop as a
youth culture independently
from the socialist unity party,
the ruling party in the GDR,
and its mass organizations
like the Free German Youth.
Although the fall of the wars and
its aftermath ended the founding
of the universal hip-hop family,
Electric B's activities show
how he used DJing and rap
to create an artist persona, which
allowed him to arrange himself
with socialism and at the same
time speak out against it.
And I would like to
show that a little bit
in detail in a few seconds.
With the help of a journalist who
supplied him with hip-hop records,
a youth club director who managed
to undermine the Free German Youth
and the youth club [foreign
language], which translates
into barn in American English,
into [foreign language].
He started performing
as the hip-hop DJ
and rapper TJ Big Blaster
Electric Boogie.
His hip-hop parties
attracted large crowds.
And while he performed
under an official license,
which you can see here, this
is what they looked like,
he did not shy away from criticizing
the socialist cultural landscape.
And I will show that in
his lyrics in a second.
So his Christian name is Alexander
Morawitz, and he got this license
for voice singing, not as
a rapper or DJ or whatever.
And this is a rather late license
from June 1989, he had one already
in 1984 and 1985, but he had
to renew it every year,
so this is a later one.
And he could he was -- he had
got a very high rating, A,
just like American grades.
So he got an A. And therefore,
he could receive payments
from the people who
booked him, between 70
and 130 marks per performance.
And sometimes his performance
would be five minutes,
sometimes his performance
would be 20 minutes,
sometimes they were even longer.
And he would get money,
and that was true
for almost every B-Boy crew too.
So they could make money and
then they invested this money
into the raw material
to make their clothing
or to buy records and
so on and so forth.
So this is Alexander Morawitz, AKA
TJ Big Blaster Electric Boogie.
So let's listen to his rap
Care, which he composed in 1988.
The following is a live recording
from the Palace of the Republic,
in January 1989, where he performed
for the youth in the
Palace Festival.
In other words, he could not get
any bigger, because the Palace
of the Republic was the biggest --
it was not only the
seat of the government,
but also it was the biggest
youth club in the GDR.
And it could not get any more
official, because you had
to be an officially licensed
artist to perform there.
So this is it.
And you can try to decipher the
words, or just read with me.
[ Music ]
[ Silence ]
Okay, so I wanted to take you
through the lyrics, of course,
because they are very
hard to understand.
He is obviously not a
native speaker of English,
and he also didn't have
English at school, right.
He had to take Russian.
And then, if you took English,
the contact hours that you had
with English were very, very few.
So what he usually did, he learned
English from record sleeves,
of course, from the covers of
LPs, and then also he had friends
from the Technical University in
Dresden who were native Britons,
and they were lectures for the
University and taught English.
And he kind of wrote his text
in German and translated them
into English and then kind of
polished them and gave them
to his friends and they
said, this is English enough,
or this is not English
enough [laughter].
So this is how it happened.
And you can see the
gestures of boasting, right.
I'm the best, I'm the greatest.
And he's I think music history,
so he doesn't really identify
with anything of the
German musical tradition.
He has his posse, right,
who was running this town,
not the mayor of Dresden, it
was he and his posse, right.
[laughter] And so [inaudible]
everybody else,
and especially the
compromised money musician.
So compromise is basically or refers
to the compromise that you had
to kind of deal with when you wanted
to make music, to perform in front
of this commission
that would assess you
and then hand out these licenses.
And usually, money musicians kind of
self-censored in order to do that.
So they said, okay, we're not going
to speak up against the state,
we're not going to have too
much guitars, or we're not going
to have this line in there.
But we're very conformist, and
this gives us a chance at least
to make music and to perform.
And that's something he criticizes.
Although he has a license too.
But the way he did it was,
since nobody spoke English
in these assessments commissions.
He handed them the German
translations, and in the space
between the German and the
English, he could kind of slip
in conformist German lines and
not conformist English lines.
So that's how he did it.
And that's why he could call
everybody else money musicians,
because they only did it for the
money, but he did it for a cause.
And the craftsman vision
is how to do it the right,
how to play music well, but
it's without a soul for him.
So his soul is hurt when he
listens to this kind of stuff.
And he's also dissing
everybody else, right,
the compromised money
musicians running zigzag,
following the party line.
And then so he doesn't need it.
And he also is dissing them by
calling them with weaker melodies,
and he's, and this
is my favorite line,
we're laughing watching the
pointer of our soccer seeker.
The German original is or I
translate into better English now,
and please excuse my language.
We're laughing watching the pointer
of our mother fuckers, right.
So I said it before, excuse
my language [laughter].
So [inaudible] result of
this pig meat nation is
because the GDR was very proud
that it fed everybody
and it did so with pork.
So this is why he calls
it pig meat nation.
And he hates the cultural
functionaries, which he calls --
well, the people who
were responsible
for the socialist cultural landscape
are always on vacation it seems,
and that's why nothing
really good can ever happen.
And they're also suckers.
And in this void, he appears and
he brings kind of more culture,
and everybody else
better stay behind him,
because he brings more entertainment
and good times and also criticism.
So that's what he does.
I admit that I'm sure
that not everybody
in his audience always
understood him [laughter],
at least not in the
Palace of the Republic.
But he had every fortnight he
had big parties in Dresden,
and he had like an
audience, he had regulars.
And I'm pretty sure that
those people knew what he was
talking about.
And also he had regular
workshops where he invited people
to share their lyrics, to
help them with rhyming,
with the craft making beats,
and so on and so forth.
So I guess that he had he could
reach out to this community
of hip-hoppers, and
excluding the adult world
who was keen on monitoring him.
All right, to conclude,
from 1983 to 1990,
hip-hop culture became
very much alive
in the German Democratic Republic.
A small but highly visible scene
gives the authorities positive
disposition towards African-American
culture as working-class culture,
and created its own
versions of breakdance,
graffiti, Djing, and rap.
In this process of
cultural transfer,
"Beat Street" played
a decisive role.
Originally imported in order to
educate good young socialists
about bad capitalism in America,
it had quite the opposite effect,
and instilled in many
young viewers the wish
to become a hip-hopper
in New York City.
At the same time, it served as
a role model for aspiring B-Boys
and B-Girls, graffiti
writers, and DJs, and rappers,
to emulate what they
saw on the movie screen.
Against their performances,
be it on official stages,
be it on the streets,
the controlling agency strategies
proved useless in the long run.
The fall of Iron Curtain also meant
a last curtain for hip-hop culture
in the GDR, at least for a while.
Apart from the new challenges
that came with having to adjust
to a new political system,
hip-hoppers had to cope
with the collapse of
socialist landscape
that had promoted and
fostered hip-hop.
Although it had done so with the
intention to control and steer it
into the right direction,
acrobatic folk dance, right,
many B-Boy crews had profited
from the money, opportunities,
and perks that this
arrangement had included,
such as free practice
space, etcetera.
Now that it was gone and other
things were more important,
many hip-hoppers took
a hiatus from hip-hop.
However, in the early '90s,
they found back together,
often in concert with
peers from the West.
And in East-Western collaborations,
they founded new crews who danced,
rapped, spray-painted
graffiti, and made music.
Thus, they contributed to the
process of reunifying Germany
after 1990, but that's
another chapter
that I haven't researched yet.
So thank you very much
for your attention.
[ Applause ]
Questions?
Yes, Robert.
There's a mic.
>> Thank you very much, and
very, very interesting talk.
This might be outside the
scope of your research,
but do you have any idea how --
when you see in West Germany that
they are also taking up this sort
of hip-hop culture, do
you see any transfer?
Or do you see any different
interpretations
in West Germany compared to how
the East Germans are taking this
as a means of sort of
rebellion against authority?
>> Leonard Schmieding:
It's a good question.
If you look at how hip-hop
got into West Germany,
was by African-American
GIs and the military bases,
the American military bases play
the most important role in this.
And so young teenagers from West
Germany could actually meet these
GIs in the clubs, and they
would bring the records,
they would bring the know-how,
and they knew how to dress well
as a hip-hopper and
so on and so forth.
So you had this is the main
kind of I guess contrast, right,
main difference between
these two scenes.
I think that due to the fact
that hip-hop in the GDR was kind
of was transported by
already a stereotype, right.
Because "Beat Street" was basically
not received very well even in 1984
in the United States, because
it was already deemed dead.
With the recording industry
and record industry,
they basically already had
exported hip-hop enough
and it was drained of its soul.
So everything that could then
be exported was not the real
thing anymore.
And "Beat Street" conveyed
that in a sense.
And it's not taking place in its
original place, it's Queens, right,
and not the Bronx, where
they shot the movie.
But the GIs, they were real like
disc jockeys, or they had knowledge,
and I guess they showed
it and they shared it.
And I guess the way of looking
at African-Americans in East
and West is different this way.
And in terms of rebellion,
I think it's worth noticing
that in West Germany,
African-American GIs barely had
a public space due to the racism
within the Armed Forces,
American Armed Forces,
but also in West Germany society.
And they kind of built a coalition
with the immigrants
Turks population.
So Funkadelic, the first and for
a long time only black music club
in Frankfurt, in West Germany, very
close to all of the American bases,
of course, was run by a young Turk.
So I guess you had
minority populations
and they joined forces somehow.
And in East Germany, you
didn't have it that much.
I mean, you had African contract
workers from Angola, Mozambique,
and sometimes also Cuba, and
they were very like attractive
for the young B-Boys because they
would bring some authenticity
to the breakdance crews, which
is highly problematic, of course.
But they were ghettoized in
the GDR by the regime already.
They could only live
in certain cities,
in certain dwellings,
and so on and so forth.
But they kind of made it out there
sometimes and then intermingled
but not in a way that it
happened in West Germany.
And I guess West Germany
was more commercialized
from the very beginning because
you could just buy Nike and Puma,
Adidas wear, and you
could buy all the records.
And in the GDR, you had to be
a little bit more inventive
and you had to improvise more.
So that's the main
differences, and also I think
that speaks a little bit about
the potential of rebellion.
Yes, please.
>> Thanks.
You mentioned that English
wasn't going to work.
And I wonder whether "Beat Street,"
when it came out, was
dubbed or subtitled?
And in either case, how faithful
was it to the original script?
Or were there kind of
strategic changes made?
>> Leonard Schmieding: So
what I know is that they --
it was dubbed, there
was no subtitling.
And they bought -- the GDR
bought the West German version.
So it was dubbed by a
company in West Germany.
So you can't really speak
of any strategic changes,
that you should speak like in
socialist terms to the audience.
The only strategic
changes are in terms
of cultural legibility I guess.
So I haven't compared the
two scripts, of course,
but I know that sometimes,
like maybe [inaudible] a female is
translated differently in German,
a different context, but basically
it carries the same message.
Thank you.
Yeah, and then.
>> Yeah. Growing up in the middle
of the United States at this time,
I mean, I was 12 years old when
this came out, it's interesting
that the assimilation of hip-hop
culture that you're talking
about in East Germany was
essentially taking place
simultaneously in the
middle of the country.
Because New York might as well
have been East Germany to someone,
you know, from Oklahoma,
like myself, or,
you know, around in that area.
And one thing that I find
interesting about this is that
"Beat Street" was part of a whole
bunch of films, similar films,
that came out around the same time.
And from the perspective of
my sort of group growing up,
"Beat Street" had a kind of
sense of authenticity culturally
that something like breaking,
for instance, did not have,
was very sort of sanitized, by the
book sort of movie, that, you know,
they taught the white
girl how to breakdance
and all this sort of thing.
And it was that very much
a Hollywoody sort of thing.
And I'm wondering if those
other movies made any sort
of showing in East Germany?
Because it sounds like it
was a little more thoughtful,
the way that the film was
introduced, "Beat Street" that is.
And these others would've
not been of much interest.
But in the United States, it
at the time seemed to be that
"Beat Street" had a kind
of authenticity to it,
but Hollywood needed to sanitize
all of that even further and put
out things like breaking for people
who weren't comfortable
with what was going on.
>> Leonard Schmieding:
Yeah, good question.
So "Beat Street" I should mention
is also a Hollywood production,
but it was produced by an
African-American and also directed
by an African-American, Stan
Lathan was the director.
And also, when I looked in the
archives, in East Germany's Ministry
of Culture, the division of
film, I mean, they had to rate
and then approve everything,
right, in communist times.
They looked at things
like "Breakin'"
and "Breakin' 2, Electric Boogaloo."
They did not look at "Star Wars" and
they did not look at "Wild Style."
But since they did not decide
to approve and to import it,
there's no further mentioning
of the movies, and I don't know
like how they liked it or
how they didn't like it.
But I think the fact that
Harry Belafonte is the producer
and he was almost communist
enough for the regime to --
for their cause, they decided
to go with "Beat Street."
And for the youngsters,
it was authentic enough.
And for the officials,
it was super authentic.
So I mean, there's a whole
authenticity debate, right.
But this portrayal was
for them the real thing.
>> Wonderful presentation.
I was just wondering how
East German hip-hop compared
to other communist
countries or contrasted
with other communist
countries at the time?
>> Leonard Schmieding:
In terms of hip-hop?
>> Yeah.
>> Leonard Schmieding: Yeah.
It's also a very good question.
So you know that in Hungary and
the Czech Republic and in Poland,
they had some hip-hop culture.
I don't know anything
about the Soviet Union.
The Soviet Union did not have any
hip-hop movies, that's for sure,
because they would
have imported those.
That's my guess.
Starting in 1987, they had
international hip-hop, breaking,
breakdance competitions
in Szolnok and Hungary.
And people from France, from
Switzerland, from Austria,
countries that had some
kind of communist tradition,
not from West Germany,
and then from Hungary,
they met there and they competed.
And some B-Boy crews from
East Germany went there,
also some soloists,
dancers went there.
And I have some video
material, which is super funny,
but I don't have any
written sources on that.
The only thing that -- and I'm
still waiting for some answer
from the Stasi archive because
one drew decided to defect,
so they made it out of the GDR by
way of Szolnok, in Hungary in 1987.
And that was a big
scandal and a big --
it was just horrible for the adult
like parents who went with them,
right, because they had kind
of vouched for this youth
that everything would be okay.
Hungary and Czechoslovakia were in
high demand because you could buy
or get spray cans there and
other like Western goods
that were needed for hip-hop.
So I have a whole like scrapbook
from Dresden, which is that big,
and it's a mixture between a
diary and newspaper clippings
but also some sketches
and photographs.
And it shows them in
like total B-Boy wear,
but also with a bare
upper body in Budapest.
And this is where they could buy
Cocoa-Cola and Marlboro cigarettes,
they could be a little bit more,
you know, free or capitalist.
So that was in high demand for them.
That was basically
it, not many meetings.
Nowadays it's a little bit
different because there are ties
between the different
cities at least.
Thank you.
Yes, please.
>> This may be a little bit
outside of the parameter
of the research you presented today,
but have you done any research
into the influence that some German
artists have had on early hip-hop,
like George Jones or craft work?
>> Leonard Schmieding: Only a
little bit about [inaudible],
but not in depth research.
I just know that it's kind of
like Afrika Bambaataa is --
or hip-hop in Germany as a
whole is kind of full circle
or [inaudible] coming full
circle, because [inaudible]
as a German band basically
pioneered electronic music,
that Afrika Bambaataa then
picked up and made hip-hop with.
And then Afrika Bambaataa was the
person that was in high demand
for East German hip-hoppers.
And so that kind of music
tradition is like going
across Atlantic at this time.
Not that much -- I haven't done
that much research about it.
It's also very hard since the Iron
Curtain was actually quite a good
kind of border for material goods.
So you couldn't buy any vinyl
records in East Germany.
And I should mention
that in West Germany,
they just didn't know
what records to buy,
so they were not there
either, right.
So the GIs had to kind of bring
them to the PFs on the base
and then they would be available.
So it was very slow.
And then some music
journalists from East Germany,
they would get the records
without having to ask for them.
So they would be [foreign language],
that's what the German term is.
They would just get them
because for their review.
But they gave them away sometimes.
So if there's still one journalist
who has this record collection,
and could tell me which records he
had and which records he gave away,
then I could tell you more
about how it was used.
But it's gone, I'm sorry to say.
>> Thank you.
I was really fascinated by this
idea of second culture that was used
as a kind of wider theoretical
framework by the government
to understand world
culture, it sounds like.
And I'm curious if you
could speak more broadly,
if you know it was used
elsewhere in the socialist bloc?
And what other cultural phenomena
were considered to be sort
of second culture worth importing?
>> Leonard Schmieding: Thank you.
I've only found it like in GDR
publications, I've only found it
in terms of hip-hop, when they
talk about hip-hop in the 1980s.
I would have to go back to these
magazines and public discourse
to look whether it was also
used with blues or jazz.
But I'm not really -- I'm uncertain.
I'm guessing probably
not, because it was more
like a folk culture,
blues and jazz were.
And then Chazenski, the
historian, he used it in his
like multi-volume work
on the history
of the everyday of
the German people.
And there's a long
chapter using this term.
And it's a hard read, because it's
not only this communist lingo,
it's also like citation
after citation by people
like not only Linen or Marks
but like [foreign language],
you name all these
communist socialist big names.
Great thinkers and great citations,
but it's not very concise
[laughter].
So I haven't found it
with anything else.
But maybe a good place to
start would be the preparations
for the World Youth Festival in
Berlin, in 1973, because that's
when Berlin kind of first
under Hannukah opened --
the GDR wanted to be a little
bit more open to the world
and show how modern
socialism could be.
I mean, behind the scenes, they
were very like rigid with the Stasi
and everything, and they
cleansed the city of it,
like every element
that they didn't want.
But the solidarity with the
oppressed was a big topic there.
So you might f ind stuff there.
Okay, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.